you took the most famous selfie in the
world at the Oscars by mistake really it
was so funny because the whole joke was
I was telling Daryl you you ruined it in
the most fit way I I completely messed
up Ellen DeGeneres's joke she was trying
to make a joke about trying to to her
and Meryl Streep they were gonna take a
selfie and that she couldn't take it it
was a
mind to break the internet that Meryl
and I would have the most retweets so
right now I'm going to take a picture of
us and then we'll see if we can break
the record for the most retweets and I
was sitting in the same road I thought
oh my God this is like something's wrong
Channing Bradley we ain't coming down I
want you in it she's like I'll just get
up and take it for them and I was like
Bradley you know Bradley no no I got it
right in here I'll tell you no I'm doing
it so more people jumped in than I even
imagined would
oh sorry and you took the best picture
and you actually took that picture
[Applause]